after the worst mass shooting in
Canadian history the most sweeping gun
controls the country has ever introduced
shocking and horrific images of the
aftermath of a rampage by a lone gunman
in Nova Scotia prompted the federal
government to ban about 1500 types of
semi-automatic military-grade rifles the
prime minister said it was time to get
rid of guns that mostly harm human
beings these weapons were designed for
one purpose and one purpose only to kill
the largest number of people in the
shortest amount of time
there is no use and no place for such
weapons in Canada the list of prohibited
weapons includes hundreds of versions of
the ar-15 assault rifle last used in a
mass shooting in Canada in 2017 when a
gunman killed six men in a Quebec City
mosque such attacks are much rarer here
than in the United States
Canadians are far more accustomed to
hearing of mass killings across the
border such as the Las Vegas mass
shooting that left 58 people dead in
2017 an assault weapons ban like this is
widely supported in Canada and polls
indicate that's only increased since the
events in Nova Scotia gun rights
advocates say it's a politically
expedient move that ignores the fact
that most gun killings in Canada come
from illegal handguns smuggled across
the u.s. border and not from assault
weapons some measures in the new
legislation are similar to those in New
Zealand which banned assault rifles and
conducted a highly successful buyback
program in response to the Christchurch
mosk massacre last year Canada too will
offer a two-year amnesty to existing
legal owners of banned weapons and will
offer compensation there may also be new
laws coming to allow cities to ban
handguns which are already tightly
regulated gun control advocates have
welcomed the new measures and say they
look forward to further action to make
Canada a much safer country
Daniel Locke al-jazeera Toronto